من بيروت ينضم لنا الخبير العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه العميد الياس حنا عميد
الياس
تصريحات تتحدث عن طبيعه هذه المرحله من
الحرب بانها حرجه وبان الاشهر المقبله هذه
تصليح الرئيس بايدن تصريحات تركيا من
الاشهر المقبله ستشتد فيها المعارك ويتزمن
ذلك مع
طوفان من الاسلحه يصل الى اوكرانيا اعلنت
عن الولايات المتحده كيف تصف هذه المرحله
زين هي مرحله الاستعداد للمرحله القادمه
عامل الطقس قد يكون جزء اساسي بالتاخير
بسبب الوحوش الجليد وما شابه ولكن
العمليات لن تتوقف المرحله القادمه ستكون
مرحله الاستعداد الفريقان يريدان هذه
المرحله للاستعداد مع فريق بسيط ان الرئيس
بوتين يريد وقف العمليات لاعاده ترتيب
القوى
والتعويض خاصه الخطا الاخير في ماكيكا
ولكنه من الجهه الاوكرانيه يريدون الحفاظ
على هذه الاندفاع او الممنوعهم يوم ياتي
سلاح جديد مدرع هو اكثر من عربه مصابه
مصفحه ولكن اقل من دبابه اساسيه هذه
الاليات هي تؤمن حركيه مهمه زين وكاننا
نستعد لمرحله هجوم او هجوم عكسي بمكان ماء
خاصه في جنوب اوكرانيا في ذا فروجيا في
خرسانه هل نفهم عميد الياس ان المرحله
المقبله بالنسبه لاوكرانيا هي مرحله
هجوميه للدفاعيه
بالطبع لانه اليوم المرحله المومنتم
الاندفاع مع الاوكران يبقى اليوم السلاح
اللازم بدانا نرى باتريوت ايرس نسام وعده
اسلحه دفاعيه جويه وبدانا نتائج على صعيد
المسيرات ياتي البتريوت بطاريتين يعني ان
نتحدث عن 64 صاروخ جاهز وكاننا الاوكراني
يريدون تامين الحمايه الجويه وذلك بهدف او
سيطر وذلك بهدف تامين العمليات العسكريه
هذه الاليات هي ليست دفاعيه التي اعطيها
من لبرادلي الماردن وحتى البوش ماستر
الاستراليه وحتى الكلبي في التركيه كلها
هجوميه تحمل العسكر لنقلهم الى الجبهه
الاماميه ولكن يبقى كيف سيستعد الجيش
الروسي في المقابل
هل واقعي الحديث عن نزع السلاح الجيش
الروسي حينما تخرج هذا التصريحات من
الجانب الاوكراني باستخدام الصواريخ
وباستخدام هذه الترسانه التي تحدثت عنها
هل يمكن ان يصل الامر الى نزع السلاح
الروسي او بمعنى ادق
انهاء فعالياته في الميدان
زين الخطه الاوكرانيه تعتمد على التالي
نقاط قوه الجيش الروسي هي في المدفعيه هي
في الدبابات وهذا الهيمس يضرب هذه
المدفعيه وهذه الدبابات الجديده او
العربات المصفحه هي ضد الدبابات اليوم
الهدف هو تحرير قدر الامكان من الارض
وبالتالي العمل على منع الروس او الجيش
الروسي من تشكيل وحده وجهازيه قتاليه مهمه
للمرحله القادمه من هنا ياتي قصف مكيفك
400 جندي على مسافه 13 كيلو متر وفي محيط
ملتهب سوفت كريمينا ومن الجنوب محمود فاذن
اليوم هو المنع او الدستراكشن كما يقال
بالانجليزيه هذا ما يفعله الاوكراني كي لا
يجعل الجيش الروسي يكون مستعدا وكاملا مع
جهازيه كامله لهجوم ما في مرتقب ما بعد
الشتاء ولكن ماذا عن الاستعداد الروسي هل
يمكن ان يزيد من الاسلحه المستخدمه
والعتاده التي يدفع به في هذه الحرب لانه
موازين القوه هل يمكن ان تسمح روسيا بان
تتساوى
اليوم ال- ال- النياز- الموازين القوى هي
للجيش الروسي عددا وعددا اليوم طريقه
القتال تختلف هناك طريقه اوكرانيه جديده
حديثه وهذا ما تبين في القصف على ما كيفك
وهناك الطريقه التقليديه الطريقه
التقليديه الروسيه هي مدفعيه على الجبهه
قصف ومن ثم الانتقال هذه المدفعيه همم
مياده بحاجه الى ذخيره الى تجمع هذا ما
يفعله على سبيل المثال الهايمر يمنع
التشكل هذه المنظومه كي لا يكون هناك نقاط
قوه اساسيه في اي هجوم مرتقى روسي
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد